oh
[Music]
okay a little slow back down so sure
coming around
all right so
it's like you're going to find rokio
your your rokio is right here okay
and you do want to go
you want to play the shoulder elbow
wrists off each other okay you can come
around and you go to roll kill
okay but he
counters by coming around you see
go back
so let's let's go slow let's say I'm
trying to do rokio he counters by coming
around and dropping his elbow underneath
you're not gonna get broken so you don't
fight for rokio
you're in rokio he comes around and you
let rokio go and you're in Nico okay
so make sure
I I tend to think of it that way
I'm trying to rokio even though it's
Keyhole do I do I feel and sense rokio
being passed through I don't go to the
wrist okay
boom
around
boom okay
next statement when he comes around go
ahead
he's coming around you don't want to
crush him down here
you want to keep
you want to keep his kazushi going so
you're not trying to break his wrist
you're going to go in his body
you make him move past you
so watch for that I won't go fast but
I'll go smooth and you're gonna see
how I'm doing that
I do not advise that UK to want to lay
down there
okay you're going to add tensions to the
wrist law
[Music]
I can move past you so you'll have this
opening
for the final Pig
and practice being in his Center and now
in his wrist
so there it is I I want to open your
mind more
[Music]
to the rokio
okay
so again
as as he
counters the rokio he's saying drops his
elbow you see he's trying to drop the
silver he's like yeah he's he's who
would put themselves in Nico that's the
strategy of wristwatch I don't chase
wrist lock I don't chase risks
I don't chase the risk the dude puts
himself in the technique do you do you
understand that okay so
when you're here
on the EQ
for example it's as he's he's trying to
get up that post he's trying to get up
where is he going broke you
see
it's not I would never take someone to
equal and then decide to go rokio okay
likewise I'm not gonna go from here and
to there you see that that that Gap to
there that's where you're gonna lose the
guy right because I don't I'm not
controlling his elbow
you see I have this here I have his
elbow okay and now he has to do
something with it oh he does do
something with it you can see and what I
use this technique for
is to get him
out from in front of me you see he's in
front of me right so I'm gonna make him
go fight me
again it's because you're in his Center
so when I when I'm here like this uh I'm
going to be
in his sentence you can take one hand
you can take your hand off you you can
take your body off and you still
are moving him
by his Center
all that
so that you understand that it's an
energetic manipulation and not a
skeletal manipulation because sometimes
you're doing weird things to get him to
move that way well you took the you took
the lock off okay so
foreign
down
and make him go that way
but I don't have to drop his forearm
down
and make him go that way so don't do
something
so mechanical that is to the detriment
of the actual lock that you're trying to
use for him to fall into okay do you
guys got that so
if you pay attention I'm doing a little
different every single time because the
the the surface level the mechanical
level is not important that that's not
important
okay so don't don't try to find some
in some way here you are uh he does the
counter fill his body boom and move his
body
[Music]
foreign
okay try it again